Deloitte real-estate is producing the
the London crane survey for an hour for
about 20 years and the crane service a
bit of a metaphor we go out and sort of
obviously don't understand construction
and yeah in the light in the in the in
the recent period we've seen a
significant amount of construction so
the fact we've dropped 9% in this in
this last period to twelve point six
million square foot of construction as
you say is really a function of some of
that construction you know coming to a
conclusion and we've seen a slight
decline in the sort of the amount of
construction that's that starting so the
the tagline for the survey this year is
sort of approaching with caution I think
developers are sort of you know taking
things forward slightly more cautiously
but not panic stations absolutely not
the twelve point six million is is
wherever at the long-term 10-year
average is ten million so we're still a
well it well above that so you know
there's no there's no great decline in
that sense I'm very interestingly over
the last six months while developments
in the city have sort of slowed down by
about 11 percent on six months ago in
the West End Oh
20 percent yep no that's true so there's
almost more starts in the West End than
we've ever recorded before the West End
tends to be smaller developments but ya
know the West End is is is quite busy at
the moment and presumably the opening of
Crossrail next year will that give it
another shot in its Locker or has is
that all priced in if you like quite a
lot of so you know where the Crossrail
stations are is obviously well-known and
a lot of that is is planned but you're
right that you know that those those new
stations always create a sort of a
demand and a sort of demand in those new
areas so yeah that does sort of create a
changing environment and I guess we have
to wait now for Crossrail to to give it
the next sort of leg of the date of
growth what about the cost of building
materials is there having much of a
bearing on activity cost of building
materials is is is is quite difficult
we've you might expect as you sort of
come up come off the sort of
construction and instruction declines a
bit that there's what the cost of
construction would come down and I'm
sure developers would prefer to see that
the reality is though that the
combination of the the the impact of
brexit and the decline of sterling has
meant many of the materials that we buy
if we buy them from Europe I buy them
from the US are actually costing us sort
of 20
percent more so material price has added
into some of the cost increases we've
seen in recent years so yeah actually
construction prices we do it we do a
complimentary survey at the same time
and go out to about 300 sort of trade
contracts and subcontracts in the market
to understand how they see the market
and they are still seeing prices rising
not as much but they're still seeing
prices going upwards at the moment so
that's that's difficult you know
developers would rather see it come down
I'm Mike Randolph and Deloitte's good to
have you on thanks are joining me